we
you brought up anarchy earlier uh
it's an interesting question because
you've kind of said
politicians i mean part of it is a
little bit joking but
politicians are you know not good people
yep
so but we should have some
so so you have an opposition to
anarchism
so they first of all they weren't always
not bad people that is
i gave examples of people who engaged in
political life who i think were good
people basically
um and and but they think they get worse
over time
if the system is corrupt and i think the
system unfortunately
even the american system as good as it
was was founded on quicksand and have
corruption built in
um they didn't quite get it and and they
needed invent to get it so i'm not
blaming them i don't think they hold
they show any blame you needed
a philosophy in order to completely
fulfill the promise that is america
there's a promise that is the founding
of
so the the place where corruption
sneaked in
is the lack of in some way of the
philosophy underlying the nation
absolutely so so it's it's christianity
it's it's
it's a you know not to hit on another
controversial topic
it's religion uh which on which
undercuts their morality
so the founders were explicitly
christian and altruistic in their
morality
implicitly in terms of their actions
they were completely secular and they
were
they were very secular anyway but in
their morality even they were secular so
there's nothing in christianity that
says that they that the you have an
inalienable right to pursue happiness
that's unbelievably self-interested in a
based on
kind of a moral philosophy of ego of
egoistic moral philosophy
but they didn't know that and they
didn't know how to ground it
they implicitly they had that fast
thinking that gut
they told them that this was right and
the whole enlightenment that period from
john locke
on to really to um
to hume that period is about pursuit of
happiness using reason in pursuit of the
good life
right but they can't ground it they
don't really understand what reason is
and they don't really understand
what happiness requires and they can't
detach and fell from christianity
they're not allowed to politically and
they can't i think conceptually you just
can't
make that big break rand is an
enlightenment thinker in that sense she
is what should have followed right after
right she should have come there and
grounded them in
the secular and in the egoistic and the
aristotelian view of morality
as as a as a as a code of values to
basically to guide your life to guide
your life towards happiness
that's aristotle's view right um
so they didn't have that so
you you know so i think that government
is necessary it's not a necessary evil
it's a necessary
good because it does something good
and the good that it does is it
eliminates coercion from society it
eliminates violence from society it
eliminates
the use of force between individuals
from society
and that but see the argument like
michael mouse would make
give me a chance here yeah why can't you
apply the same kind of
uh reasoning that you've effectively
used for the rest
of uh mutually agreed upon institutions
that are driven by capitalism
that we can't also hire forces to
protect us from the violence
to ensure the stability of society that
protects us from the violence
why why draw the line at this particular
place right
well because there is no other place to
draw a line and there and there is a
line
and by the way we draw lines other
places right um
we uh we don't
vote we don't um we don't have
we don't determine truth in science
based on competition
right so that's a that's a line but it's
online first of all some people might
say
i mean there's competition in a sense
that you have alternate theories but at
the end of the day
whether you decide that this he's right
or he's right is not based
on the market it's based on
facts on reality on objective reality
you have to you and and some people will
never accept that this person is right
because they don't see
the stream so first of all what they
reject what most anarchists reject even
if they don't admit it
or recognize it is they object they
they reject objective reality
in which sense so like okay right so
there's a whole
so the the whole realm of law
is a scientific realm
to define for example the boundaries of
private property
it's not an issue of competition it's
not an issue of
of of uh of i have one system and you
have another system
it's an issue of objective reality and
now it's
more difficult than science in a sense
because
it's more difficult to prove that my
conception of property is correct and
you're
correct but there has there is a correct
one
in reality this is a correct vision it's
more abstract
but look somebody has to decide
what property is so i have i have to
find my property is defined
by certain boundaries and i have a
police force
and i have a judiciary system that backs
my vision
and you have a claim against my property
you have a claim against my property and
you have a police force
and your judiciary system that backs
your claim
who's right so the our definitions of
property are different yes our
definitions of property oh
our claim on the property is different
so what what so so
can you just agree on the definition of
property
and but why should we agree right your
judicial system is one definition
property
my district system is done you you think
that there's no such thing as
intellectual property rights and your
whole system believes that
yeah and my whole system believes there
is such thing so you are duplicating my
books
and handing them out to all your friends
and not paying me a royalty
yeah and i i think that's wrong
my judicial system and my police force
think that's wrong
and we're both living in the same
geographic area
right so we have overlapping
jurisdictions
now the anarchists would say well well
negotiate why should we negotiate
my system is actually right there is
such a thing as intellectual property
rights there's no negotiation here
you're wrong and you should either pay a
fine or go to jail
yeah but why can't because it's a
community there's multiple
there's multiple parties and it's like a
majority vote they'll
they'll hire different forces that says
yeah euron is onto something here with
the definition of property
and we'll go with that so anarchist
pro-democracy
in in in the majority rule sense well i
think so i think i think anarchy
you know so it promotes like emergent
democracy right like this no it doesn't
it it i'll tell you what it
promotes it promotes emergent uh strife
and civil war and violence
constant uninterrupted violence because
the only way to settle the dispute
between us
since we both think that we are right
and we have
guns behind us to protect that and we
have a legal system we have a whole
theory of ideas
is is you're stealing my stuff
how do i get it back i invade you right
i take over you know and and who's gonna
who's gonna win
that bad the smartest guy no the guy
with the biggest guns
see but the anarchists would say that
they're using implied
like the state uses implied uh
force they're already doing violence
because they they they take the state as
it is today
and they refuse to engage in the
conversation about what a state
should and could look like and how we
can create
mechanisms to protect us from this state
using those
those dudes but look this is my view of
anarchy is very simple
it's a ridiculous position it's
infantile
i mean i really mean this right and and
i'm sorry to michael but and all the
other
very very smart very very smart
anarchist because anarchist is never
you won't find a dumb anarchist right
because dumb people know it wouldn't
work
you have to have it's absolutely true
you
have to have a certain iq to be an
anarchist that's true they're all really
intelligent all intelligence and the
reason is
that you have to create
such a mythology in your head
you have to create so many
rationalizations
any joe in the street knows it doesn't
work
because they can understand what happens
with two people who are
armed are in the street and have a
dispute and there's
no mechanism to resolve that dispute
yeah
that's objective that sep and this is
where it gets subjected
that's objective the whole point of
government is
that it is the objective authority for
determining
the truth in one regard in regard to
force
because the only alternative to
determining it
when it comes to force is through force
the only
way to resolve disputes is through force
or through this negotiation which is
unjust because if one party's right and
one party's wrong why negotiate
and and this is the point i'm not
against competition of governance i'm
all for competition of governance
we do that all the time it's called
countries the united states
has a certain governance structure the
soviet union had a government structure
mexico has a governance structure
and they're competing yeah and we can
observe the competition we and
in a in my world you could move freely
from one governance to another
if you didn't like your governance you
would move to a better governance system
but they have to have autonomy within a
geographic area
otherwise what you get is complete and
out of civil war
the law needs to be objective and there
needs to be one law over a piece of
ground and if you disagree with that law
you can move somewhere else where they
may
this is why federalism is such a
beautiful system even within the united
states we have states
and on certain issues we're allowed to
disagree between states like the death
penalty some states do
some states don't fine and now i can
move from one state if i don't like it
but there's certain issues you cannot
have disagreement slavery for example
this is why we had a civil war
but let me one other argument against
anarchy
markets exist with forces being
eliminated
uh as i can say that again marketing
markets exist
where the rule of force has been
eliminated
the rule of force yes so
a market will exist if we know
that you can't pull a gun on me and just
take my stuff i am willing to engage in
transaction with you
if we have an implicit understanding
we're not going to use force against
each other
so the force has something special to it
yes it's a special
it overrides because we're still
agreeing we can manipulate each other
yes but first we can force kind of
so there's something fundamental about
violence
force is a is a fundamental force it's
the anti-reason
it's the anti-life it's the anti
force against another person and it what
it does is shuts down the mind
right so in order to have a
market you have to extract force
that's fast how can you ever mark it in
force
yeah when i there's an instagram channel
called nature's metal
where it has all these videos of
animals basically having a market of
force
yes but that shuts down the ability to
reason and animals don't need to because
they can't
exactly so the innovation that is human
beings is our capacity to reason and
therefore
the relegation of force to the animals
we don't do
force civilization is where we don't
have force
and so what you have is you cannot have
a market and that
which a market requires the elimination
of it
and i you know i i don't debate formally
these guys but i
interact with them all the time right
and you get these absurd arguments where
you know david friedman will say
that's milton friedman's son he will say
something like well in somalia
in the northern part of somalia where
they have no government you have all
these wonderful you have these tribal
uh uh tribunals of these tribes the
neighbors all disputes
yeah barbarically they use
sharia law they have no respect for
individual rights no respect for
property
and the only reason they have any
authority is because they have guns and
they have power
and they have force and they do it
barbarically
there's nothing civilizing about the
courts of somalian and and they write
about
pirates and because they view force they
don't view forces something unique
that must be extracted from human life
and that's why anarchy has to devolve
into violence
because it treats forces just what's a
big deal with negotiating
you know over guns
you